>>> A FIGHFOE FUTU
N SPECIANATEXAAT'S HAPPENING TO.
11 REPUBUN
TRUMMESSAGE.
PE  ANY CNC?
ANYWHERE EVER..HE'SNG TO GO
>> THE BIG LIES ARE WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID.
IT REALLY SHOOK ME.
>> Reporter: THEEPN
ELTI>> YOU ARECERNED OF THE Y,
D TRUMP.
QUESON DON'T LIKE THE MAN.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKUSE
BEEN IN A HARDN IN THE
FAST FOUR YEARS, I FELT LIKE I
HAD TOOTR HIBEE S HAVE GONE SOA
THE LEFT.
REPUBLICANS RUNNIN TO FILL
THE HOUSE SEAT LEF
CONGRESSMAN RON RICE WHO DIED
AFTER CONTRACTING COVID-19 IN
FEBRUARY.
>> F I HADAND .P AND
SAY THISS T
REPUBLICAN PARTY SHOILD BE.
BEEN LAUNCHING REPUBLICANS BUT
TEN DETHE RACE THAT'O GO
TOP TWO
>> THE ELECTION WAS NOT
'S RCTON THE RACEORY OQANON AND.
GROUNDHEE SPEAKI
VOTERSE? I HEOWH
ON JANUAHAN MAD
OF TAND WHAT I AM SAYING.E SORTS
35% TO THE P THAT'S OPENTH MESSA
A F
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
WHR PARTY? I DON'T KNOW.Y CONCE.
>> THE OTHER REPUBLICANSERE
N THDO TRUMP'S
>> MEING HERE IGA.S BATHE PARTY
COUNTRY.
E
I DON'T TH HE T
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S  WITH THE RO
CON  ANDIDOW
MAGA IN HET  FULLY LEANEO FILLR
INSTEAD FOR
HUAN.
>> HIS PRIORITY WERE STRON
S AND LIFE ANDIV
>> Reporter: I AM VOTING FOR
.
>> MICHAELHE'S VOTING, ANNE ABOT
TRUMP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK AB?
>> WELL, I DON'THINK HE'S
GOING TO M HEAD INK TOO MUCH OFH
STILL VE MUCH IN WITLD TRUMP'S .
>> Reporter: MICHAE
DENEUTURE OF THE
PRT ANS IN THE 2022
D TODEMOCRAT, I U KNOW, I OT HUG
ON AAM HUGE ONT
S YOUO'S
INTERESTED IN CHANGING THE
PARTY
OU THERE IS A TRUM
2024 FLAG RIGHT OVER THERE.
>> ReporEL E ELECTI WOT RIGGED I
RIGH PERSUASIVE AND THBIG LIE O.
>>MUCH.
>>> WA TBR MATTH
DOUD, CHIEF  FOR THE
2004W, LOOKINGTH
AGAIN, EMPHASIZEING AT THE TOP B
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATIVE
DIED OF ONE OF RUNNING ON AN
SE YOU A M
>>
IT DOES NOT SURPRISE ME AT ALL.
AREA VERLL
WHEN I HADE HAIRND
STATE REP RATS IN MUCH OFHE N .
S 85% OLARITYNG REPUBLICAHE'SY.
THIS IS WHER.
AS HE P IS EFFECTIVE OF WHERE T.
THE INRACE ITHERE ARE STMYSTERYO
OTHE VOTE, YOU CA LIKELY.
RUN-OFF.
IS THERE IS GH
ANTIUMD THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, I% OR 20% AMONG
REPUBLICANE TIRED OF
AND WANT TOOV
INTO DIFFERENT DIRECTION ANDE TT
INTEGRITER IN THAT RACE. THEETE
SALE INTO THE BIG D L OFTRUMP'S
ALL THE TH HSAYSINK THE RESUE TO
INK
LONG SHOT POINT GOOFF, DON'T REE
THAT.
T THE
REPU PTYEY
WERE FIRE AGAIN.
BIDEN BEFORE HIS J TSESSN  CONG.
CHENEY ISSUED THISN
O THSLNGR THAT MOMENT.
BUT WHEN THEDENT REACHED ME, WDA
WAY.
REMAINBLRTY? AMERICANS.OU THINK
>> NO, I THI SHEO INFLUENCE AT
EY BUYNT F
POLICIES BUTVETHAT, THERE I   -
TRACK.
ESR POSITION IN
RTY OFHERSHIP?
SHE
HAS R ANY INFLUENCE
INPARTY, THEPLZ CHENEY AREESR I
TOLSYOU BLICAN PARTY
WHAT'S FASCINATINGME A
OF THESE THINGS AS YOUCOVER ALO
THE SMALL ORWAYS TELLS A
TH E WILLING TOO
REPUANS ANT , YOU HAVE NO FLUEN
NO LONF THE REPUBLICAN
Y.
THE TABLE SKE
AT NATIONALLY AROF ANY
STATES, HA